what if I told you that the world's
first computer programmer was born over
two hundred years ago and what if that
programmer was a she lady
Ava Lovelace was her name and her genius
was nearly lost to history
daughters the famous Romantic poet Lord
Byron ADA was almost relegated as a
footnote in her father's biography in
the 19th century at the height of the
Industrial Revolution she was pushed
into the male dominion of mathematics
and science by her zealot mother men
taught by the father of the computer she
emerged as a woman far ahead of her time
and her ability to see what could
potentially be not your typical
aristocratic lady part of ADA's story
holds a shadowy secret and on her
deathbed her last wish speaks volumes
today on biographic s-- we explore the
Enchantress of number Ada Lovelace
[Music]
Ada Lovelace was born August Oh ADA
Byron in London on December the 10th
1815 to the philandering Romantic poet
Lord Byron and strictly religious
Annabella Milbank era was Lord Byron's
only legitimate child Lord and Lady
byron were members of high British
society beyond social status
they shared virtually nothing in common
Annabella was analytical and conformist
while Lord Byron can't whistle for
numbers and logic true he was a
celebrated and adored poet yet his
behavior raised more than a few eyebrows
he was known to drink from a human skull
own a pet bear and engage in numerous
love affairs with both men and women one
notorious scandal involved an affair
with his own half-sister a scorned lover
once said of Lord Byron he was mad bad
and dangerous to know not surprisingly
Annabella and Lord Byron's marriage did
not last beyond a year in a contemptuous
splits when ADA was only five weeks old
Lord Byron left the home he wrote of
this parting is my face like my mother's
my fair child ADA sole daughter of my
house and heart deeply bitter and
resentful lady Annabella covered his
portrait with a large curtain and
forbade ADA from ever looking at it for
months after Lord Byron left his infant
daughter he left England for good never
to return when ADA was 8 years old he
died of an illness in Greece while
fighting in the war of independence he
was 36 years old although ADA never met
her father she remains fascinated with
him and his poetry over the course of
her life Annabella was determined to
steer her daughter away from developing
her father's volatile poetic insanity as
she called us she truly believed Lord
Byron was mentally ill almost to the
brink of fanaticism Annabella saw to it
that ADA received an education rigorous
in mathematics and science this was a
rather unusual course of study for girls
in British Victorian society even if
Annabella herself was gifted in math
Byron referred to her as the princess of
parallelograms popular opinion of the
time favored one of ADA's later tutors
and brilliant mathematician Augustus de
Morgan
who believed women were incapable of
excelling in the discipline on the one
hand Morgan acknowledged
ADA's abilities yet in a letter to her
mother he wrote the very great tension
of the minds which they require is
beyond the strength of a woman's
physical power of application basically
what he said was that women weren't
capable because they were not as strong
as men well ADA she was gonna prove that
wrong as a young girl and into her teen
years ada was mostly isolated and did
not spend a great deal of time with her
mother still Annabella
was committed to her daughter's
education and her well-being she
employed some of the greatest
intellectual minds to tutor ADA
including William King a physician
William friends a social reformer and
Mary Somerville a Scottish astronomer
mathematician and the first woman to be
admitted to the Royal Astronomical
Society Ada and Somerville became close
friends in addition to algebra and
geometry ada was taught lessons in
history literature languages geography
music sewing and short hands these were
all common subject areas but ADA's
mother and something else that was far
far more bizarre in an effort to protect
her daughter from developing her
father's impulses Ada had to lie still
for long periods of time this was a
lesson in self-control
ada was a bright student and showed
promise for math and science at the age
of 12 after a long tour of Europe she
became obsessed with birds and with
flight she researched what she referred
to as fly ology and imaginatively and
methodically conceptualized a flying
machine that could flat its wings she
wrote to her mother I've got a scheme to
make a thing in the form of a horse with
a steam engine in the inside so
contrived as to move an immense pair of
wings fixed on the outside of the horse
in such a manner to carry it up into the
air while a person sits on its back for
her design she considered the type of
material paper silk or feathers
navigational equipment a compass and
steam the source of power in between
throwing herself into intellectual
pursuits ADA battled sickness she
frequently complained of headaches that
obscured her vision in 1829 she
contracted measles a common childhood
affliction in the 1800's the oldest
resulted in continuous bed rest for a
year and she was disabled temporarily in
1831 at the age of 16 she was finally
able to walk again
with the aid of crutches by the age of
17 ella was feeling better and in
keeping with the customs of her social
class she was presented at court and
became a popular belle of the season she
danced with and charms the various
attendees with her brilliant mind the
Industrial Revolution was in full force
by the time ADA was a teenager it was a
glorious time in history for the
Advancement of Technology and the
perfect time for the inquisitive ADA to
be coming of age make no mistake she had
the makings of a phenom she had inherent
abilities combined with rigorous
education she also had access to
intellects investors and influential
people in power all because of her
position in society all of this was the
perfect storm and meeting the famed
inventor Charles Babbage was eight as a
lightning bolt in 1833 the
seventeen-year-old ADA was among a
select group to attend a coveted party
hosted by Babbage known by many today
has the father of the computer a guest
wrote at the time
one of the three qualifications for
those who sought to be invited were
intellect beauty or rank ada with those
requirements
well she fit right in at the soiree
Babbage unveiled a small part of his
latest machine a massive mechanical
calculator known as the difference
engine the design for Babbage's engine
was revolutionary and fully constructed
it would perform the work of an army of
men crunching numbers the machine would
be powered by steam and would
methodically perform complex
calculations using only addition by
breaking it into smaller and smaller
pieces known as the method of finite
differences then it which printouts the
values into a table barrages machine had
enormous potential in the 19th century
since tables were used in many areas
including navigation astronomy and
engineering with this powerful
calculator human error would be erased
the engine was accurate within
thirty-one decimal places too many
guests that night Babbage's invention
was of metal and little more than a
party favor but not to a de de Morgan's
wife was there
Aran's later wrote of the night when
most of the guests looked on with the
expression that savages show on seeing a
looking-glass miss Byron young as she
was understood it's working and saw the
great beauty of the invention Babbage
must have been impressed with ADA's
intellect an enthusiasm for the machine
from that night on he remains her mentor
and lifelong friend
[Music]
Babbage's Difference Engine would not
come to be after a disagreement with his
engineer Joseph Clement in those days by
law the engineer owns the drawings and
after their falling-out he could not get
them back consequently the British
government also withdrew their funding
for the project this forced marriage
back to his original concept but he came
up with an even better idea in 1834 a
far more complex machine that he called
the analytical engine the analytical
engine is considered to be the world's
very first programmable general-purpose
computer the basic structure of the
engine is essentially the same as
modern-day computers of course Babbage's
machine was massive in scale his
entry-level machines would have been 45
feet long by 15 feet high but he talked
about others that were 10 times that
size nothing like it had ever been
conceived or attempted before in fact in
his lifetime only a small trial engine
was constructed this analytical engine
it consisted of four components the mill
which calculated units the store where
the data was held for processing and the
reader and printer the input and output
devices
it was truly groundbreaking and would
largely become ADA's legacy since Ada
and Babbage's first meeting she became
his protege he was the teacher and she
was the pupil after Babbage showed her
the plans for the analytical engine she
eagerly went on a tour of cotton mills
in the north of England to see the most
technologically advanced machine of the
day the jacquard loom the loom automated
the weaving of patterned silk and was
controlled by a series of punch guards
it was fascinating and it was also
controversial a cotton mill with a
jacquard loom didn't need skilled
workers to weave intricate patterns
while groups such as the Luddites were
protesting against these machines on
account of replacing workers jobs ada
was thinking something else entirely she
was deeply interested in the genius
behind the punch cards and wanted to
know how men were translating the
complicated patterns into something
simple she saw the similarities to her
beloved machine and later wrote the
analytical engine weaves algebraic
patterns just as the jacquard loom
weaves flowers and leaves for the next
ten years and between getting married
and having three children they focused
all her energy into learning
everything she could about the
analytical engine she wrote I think I am
more determined than ever in my future
plans and I have quite made up my mind
that nothing must be suffered to
interfere with them I intend to make
such arrangements in town as will secure
me a couple of hours daily with very few
exceptions for my studies after
attending one of Babbage's rare lectures
a military engineer and future Italian
Prime Minister luigi menabrea wrote an
impressive article sketch of the
analytical engine invented by Charles
Babbage Esquire the paper was extremely
detailed and mathematical and it was
also written in french ada decided to
translate the paper and since she knew
the engines so well she could add her
own thoughts to it
many years later Babbage claimed to have
told Ada to translate it and write her
own account and she responded by saying
she hadn't thought of it either way she
went about the task like a devil
possessed and when she was finished and
notes were three times as long as the
original paper later published her
completed article in scientific memoirs
an English scientific journal published
by Richard Taylor in 1843 ada only used
her initials on the paper a al standing
for gusta Ada Lovelace the part of the
paper that gives wait ages creditors
first computer programmer comes in
Section G in it ADA wrote of how the
engine could be programmed with a code
to calculate brno lean numbers this was
an algorithm to be carried out by a
machine and thus the first computer
program along with numbers ada described
how codes could be created for the
device so it could handle letters and
symbols
she also theorized a method for the
engine to repeat a series of
instructions or looping a process
computer program still used today ADA
also offered other other concepts in her
paper such as her thoughts on artificial
intelligence she wrote the analytical
engine has no pretensions whatever to
originate anything it can do whatever we
know how to order it to perform it can
follow analysis but it has no power of
anticipating any analytical relations or
truths her notes were significant in
that they captured ADA's vision for the
analytical engine and this is where she
exceeds her mentor in her understanding
of its full potential Babbage's
historian wrote a dissent failed to see
in Babbage's world his engines were
bound by number what lovely saw was that
number
represent entities other than quantity
looking back from the present high
ground of modern computing if we are
looking and sifting history for that
transition then that transition was made
explicitly by ada in that 1843 paper
Babbage was impressed with Ada and wrote
the more I read your notes the more
surprised I am and Ruby as not having
earlier explored so rich a vein of the
noblest metal the next obvious step for
the analytical engine would have been
Babbage's and ADA's crowning moment but
they would not come to pass Babbage was
known to be a difficult man and he
argued with politicians so for its
machines the relationship with
Parliament was particularly soured after
Babbage failed to deliver his government
funded difference engine the loss of
money in those days was the equivalent
to two Royal Navy warships ada had a
plan to promote the engine but it was a
sensitive subject one she breached in a
letter dated August the 14th 1843 she
asked about it if she could take over
him for promoting the analytical engine
while he step aside and focus only on
building it she entered with you will
one zoom over this last query but I
strongly advise you not to reject it
Babbage though he said no refusing all
of her conditions Babbage would not give
up control and he likely saw her asking
as an audacious move
depending on the lens used to evaluate
ADA she can be hailed as a genius a
victorian high society lady a mother and
wife a gambler adulteress or drug addict
in truth she may have been all of those
things she was like most of us complex
and contradictory as one would expect
ada married and had children she Wed
William King not William King who was
her tutor in 1835 at the age of 19 it
was 30 King seemed to be a precise
conscientious and decent man
if somewhat stiff three years after they
tied the knot King became the Earl of
Lovelace and ADA took the title Countess
of Lovelace they had three children
together
biron born May of 1836 and Isabella
called Annabella born in September of
and her Ralph Gordon born in July of
1839 for a time between 1835 and 1839
ADA focused most of our energy on
running the large household though she
found herself time for horse riding
learning the harp and studying
mathematics after their third child was
born ADA turned her attention back to
maths and the sciences and was tutored
by Auguste astir Morgan her husband King
was supportive socially the couple had
many prominent friends and acquaintances
including the writer Charles Dickens in
addition to headaches and the measles
suffered in childhood ada had recurrent
health problems as an adult after about
of cholera in 1837 she had problems with
asthma and her digestive system she was
prescribed a powerfully addictive
painkiller an opiate which was to be
taken with wine the drug altered her
personality and she reported
hallucinations and mood swings in 1841
Ada and Medora Lee the daughter of Lord
Byron's half-sister Gustus Lee were told
by ADA's mother that Lord Byron was also
medoras father in February
ada wrote to her mother I am not in the
least astonished
in fact you merely confirm what I have
for years and years felt scarcely a
doubt about but should have considered
it improper in me to hint to you that I
in any way suspected she did not blame
the incestuous relationship on her
father but instead blamed Augusta Lee I
fear she is more inherently wicked than
he ever was in the 1840s ADA herself
flirted with scandal
first with relaxed relationships with
men who are not her husband which led to
rumors she was having affairs and then
an old family vice surfaced ADA's life
took a shadowy turn in 1851 when she
began gambling on horses perhaps she was
trying in vain to raise funds for her
beloved analytical engine but no one
really knows ADA she did not act alone
she was part of a gambling ring and in
the spring season her bets went horribly
wrong it has been said ADA may have
devised a mathematical schema to predict
the winning horses
if so though it didn't work in a failed
bet at the Epsom Derby ADA ended up
owing the equivalent of roughly half a
million pounds to get out of her debt
she pawned off some of the family jewels
in 1852 ADA became gravely ill and she
took to her bet she died
painfully and slowly a future in cancer
on November the 27th 1852 at the age of
36 the exact age a father had been a few
months before she died she made an
unknown confession to her husband that
made him leave her bedside her final
wish was an act of defiance against her
mother ADA wants to be buried next to
the man who loomed large in her life but
she never knew her father
ADA's body was taken miles away from her
home to the Byron family vault inside
the Church of sin Mary Magdalene in the
small English town of Hucknall
[Music]
that brain of mine is something more
than merely mortal as time will show
ADA's contributions were married for 100
years discovered by a scientist Alan
Turing in the 1940s during the Second
World War during was something of a
kindred spirit who was also interested
in the same things she was machines that
could act upon instruction his work
ultimately led to the effort to build a
machine with the codename the bomb that
deciphered encrypted messages sent by
Hitler's armed forces cheering's work
had begun before reading ADA's notes on
the analytical engine yet he was greatly
influenced by them she along with
Babbage essentially paved the way for
Turing who is considered today as the
father of theoretical computer science
and artificial intelligence consequently
ADA's notes surfaced for the world in BV
Boden's book faster than thought a
symposium on digital computing machines
from 1953 then during the 1970s the US
Department of Defense develops a high
order computer programming language to
supersede the hundreds of different ones
then in use by the military this
programming language was named ADA ADA
is still used around the world today in
the operation of real-time systems in
the aviation healthcare transportation
financial infrastructure and space
industries in the present day an
international celebration takes place on
the second Tuesday of October that would
be Ada Lovelace day founded in 2009 by
Sue Carmen Andersen its aim is to
recognize the achievements of women in
science technology engineering and maths
it also has the goal of increasing the
profile of women in these areas and in
doing so creating new role models who
will encourage more girls into these
sectors ADA is everywhere in our modern
digital world immortalized on the
internet forever in news articles blog
posts memes quotable quotes there's even
some controversy whether or not she
deserves the claim of first computer
programmer but there is no denying her
vision surpassed any of her
contemporaries including Babbage in all
his eleven volumes of published writings
he never wrote of the aspirations for
computing like ADA hat those who have
learned to walk on the threshold of
unknown worlds by means of what are
commonly termed par excellence the exact
sciences may then with the fair white
wings of imagination I hope to saw
further into the unexplored
amidst which we live so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that will send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]